yeah
on a wild and exhilarating Journey
Through the one-piece Universe where
insane devil fruits and jaw-dropping
hockey abilities await your all and
astonishment but hold on tight because
things are about to get even crazier the
wanawaka's Unleashed an explosion of
conqueror's haki moments leaving a
Spellbound and craving for more just
imagine legendary characters engaging in
Epic clashes radiating the Crimson black
colors of the Supreme King so get ready
to set sail with Vinnie tube's top 10
one piece conquerors haki moments where
we'll be delving into the mysterious
depths of this rarest of rare powers
foreign
[Music]
getting the show on the road is Ace
division commander of the Whitebeard
pirates from a young age a showcased
exceptional Talent as the son of the
pirate king Goldie Roger who was just 10
years old when he unknowingly activated
the extraordinary ability that is
conquerors haki a power possessed by
only a handful of individuals amongst
Millions this rare gift is inherited by
those who share the lineage of its
wielders however Ace's Journey which
held immense promise was tragically cut
short during the Paramount War
celebrating Ace in a flashback after his
death we see him live up to his father's
name as he fearlessly confronts the blue
Jam Pirates unleashing his conquerors
haki to save kid brother Luffy from
certain death the entire crew is knocked
unconscious with just blue Jam left
standing why are we still here
just to suffer this moment also serves
as a Prelude to Luffy's own character
development foreshadowing his future
training in the art of haki not only
does it provide a compelling background
for this enigmatic power it also pays
tribute to Aces unrealized greatness
foreign
[Music]
we have Don Quixote doflamingo making
his grand entrance on the island of punk
Hazard cementing his position as one of
the series most menacing villains in the
lead up to this moment the straw hats
are having successfully disrupted
Duffy's underground smile production
Network narrowly evade his Fury the G5
Marines and their Commander smoker
however are unfortunate enough to be
caught in the crossfire in a shocking
turn of events the former shichibukai
Reveals His True Colors as an enemy of
the Marines and unleashes his terrifying
conquerors hockey overwhelming and
incapacitating a significant portion of
the naval Force just like Ace Duffy the
former Celestial Dragon turned pirate
had activated his hockey abilities at an
incredibly young age earning him the
unwavering loyalty of his notorious Don
Quixote family later on in the dress
roster arcadolfi engages in an intense
clash with Luffy where their haki powers
are showcased on an equal footing
however due to his subsequent defeat and
arrest Duffy is unavailable to fully
display the extent of his abilities
foreign
Luffy proudly shows off the results of
his rigorous training under Silva's
Rayleigh as he faces off against an
entire Army of fish men burying the
heavy burden of losing Ace and being
separated from his crew following the
harrowing events at sarbo the
archipelago Luffy's unshakable
determinations grow stronger comes as no
surprise evoking admiration from all who
witness him in the midst of a chaotic
Rebellion orchestrated by hody Jones in
his new Fishman Pirates against the
Neptune family that rules Fishman Island
the straw hats find themselves
confronted by no less than a hundred
thousand adversaries yet without a word
Luffy boldly renders half of the enemy
forces out of action through the sheer
force of his willpower this scene will
deeply resonate with fans of the pirate
Saga as we reflect upon this iconic
moment it becomes increasingly clear how
Oda was laying the groundwork for the
role of conquerors haki in the latter
half of the series making for a gripping
narrative that we'll tackle later
[Music]
thank you
foreign
number seven is Silva's Rayleigh the
first mate of the Roger Pirates making
his breathtaking entrance at the auction
house in saboti stunning everyone with
his two consecutive blasts of conquerors
haki undoubtedly one of the most
captivating character introductions in
the series this moment also marks a huge
step forward in the power system of the
one piece universe as Luffy's Mentor
Rayleigh is the perfect guide his
impeccable hockey control allows him to
selectively incapacitate individuals or
entire crowds as he pleases highlighting
his matchless expertise they took while
watching the wanna walk we noticed how
odar cleverly links the scene where
Rayleigh removes the explosive collar
around the enslaved kami's neck to Luffy
accomplishing the same feed during the
Sumo contest in the land of the Samurai
it's ultimately revealed that only a
select few like Rayleigh and Luffy have
the ability to imbue their bodies and
objects with conquerors haki elevating
their power to new heights it is also
worth mentioning here that Luffy's
remarkable growth over the two years he
spent training under Rayleigh is a
testament to the dark King's exceptional
skills
somebody
[Music]
at number six a legend comes to life as
red-haired Shanks asserts his massive
presence and claims his spot amongst the
great merely by sauntering onto a ship
in an incident that even the world
government couldn't ignore Shanks meets
Whitebeard aboard the Moby Dick the
Whitebeard Pirates Battleship on the
surface this seems to be an ordinary
meeting over sake but the way carried by
these two superstars is far from trivial
as shank sets foot on the deck it
becomes evident that the cheerful
Carefree pirate we know from Luffy's
childhood memories isn't to be
underestimated with a constant surge of
conquerors haki Shanks causes the weaker
wield members of whitebeard's crew to
succumb to his overwhelming presence
like swooning damsels although this
display isn't colored by the
characteristic black and white crackling
of conquerors haki we witnessed the
first in a series of Sky splitting
clashes as the two giants Collide this
is just a glimpse of the Epic haki
displays we might expect to see in the
near future especially as kaido and big
mom's imminent form means that Shanks is
the last Emperor's standing of that
generation I don't make mistakes I'm not
just like the rest of you I'm stronger
I'm smarter
I'm better
I am better
at the halfway mark is Luffy's great
scream of Despair in the Paramount war
of marineford
as Ace faces The Executioner's blade and
his seconds away from Death Luffy
unconsciously releases an enormous wave
of conquerors haki knocking out a
visibly large crowd of people what makes
this more momentous than the Fishman
island incident is that the affected
crowd includes high-ranking Marines and
seasoned Pirates the heavyweights
participated in the war all turn their
attention to the young pirate lending an
additional layer of ore to the already
electrifying scene providing an
extraordinary platform for Luffy this
incident Heralds the coming of a true
hero the unjust nature of Aces execution
based solely on his status as the pirate
King's son speaks volumes about the
world's government's distorted ideology
and sense of justice on the other hand
Luffy embodies Purity kindness and
strength fearlessly championing the just
cause even against impossible odds could
this moment be an omen of the
long-awaited arrival of Joy boy with
each passing day the anticipation for
the revelation of the truth intensifies
as we wait for the story to unravel
foreign
[Music]
next up is another stunout from Luffy
who's turning into quite the hockey
genius
[Music]
The Fearless Captain finds himself
imprisoned udon after recklessly
challenging kaido on the yonko's turf
following a grueling day participating
in the Sumo Inferno organized by kaido's
All-Star Queen Luffy is exhausted and
surrounded by the Beast Pirates but
that's not enough to stop him from
swiftly and effortlessly subduing them
with his conquerors haki ensuring a
moment of privacy for himself this
instance is a testament to Luffy's
maturity in the vast Wellspring of power
within him it's worth noting here that
these adversaries are far from ordinary
weaklings but the majority of them
possessing devil fruit abilities after
consuming artificial Smiles also this is
Luffy on an empty stomach which is one
of his biggest weaknesses although this
hockey display provides just a fleeting
glimpse of Luffy's potential we eagerly
anticipate his ongoing Journey towards
mastering hakia even greater Heights in
order to match kaido who expertly wields
conquerors haki both in physical combat
and with weapons we can be sure it won't
be very long before such Advanced
Techniques become second nature to Luffy
[Music]
when two yonkos Collide the very heavens
split open that's precisely why in our
third highest spot we have kaido and big
mom engaging in a conquerous hockey
Clash of Epic Proportions the former
crewmates turned Rivals showed us what
conqueror's hockey looks like at Emperor
level never before have we seen such
destruction capable of ripping the Earth
and causing the Seas to convulse
violently till this Mega contest we saw
both yonko square off against much
smaller opponents like kaido
intimidating useless kid in the
supernovas or big mom towering over
almost everyone and everything on whole
cake Island however watching these
goliaths go at each other is an
experience that transcends the ordinary
and strangely offers an inexplicable
sense of satisfaction the agility with
which they fight as the Vivid Hues of
their Crimson black hockey pulsates
around them is spine chili God only
knows how much Devastation they would
have caused had they not decided to form
an alliance
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
number two is the most important fight
of a bygone era featuring the pirate
king Goldie Roger and Edward Newgate AKA
Whitebeard aptly proclaimed to be the
strongest man in the world as these
legendary Rivals engage in an intense
duel on an unknown Island we as iron
fans are filled with sentiment and
excitement Roger Wheels his formidable
sword nostalgically named Ace while
Whitebeard brandishes his Majestic
naginata with each strike their hockey
infused weapons crackle releasing
massive shock waves although the contest
carries a definite air of camaraderie
it's unmistakable that both Roger and
Whitebeard acknowledge each other's
strengths and see no reason to hold back
their haki surges forth decimating
everything in its way can nearly tipping
over the Moby Dick such as their power
but it leaves even kozuki Odin
mesmerized for three days and nights the
crews of the two legends Clash
relentlessly yet their captains show no
fatigue it's impossible to think that
we'll ever get to witness another epic
battle between two such Legends in this
lifetime this encounter makes it aptly
clear that these two Star Wars of the
pirate World truly embodied the spirit
of a king
thank you
in Marco's own words here comes the
starry today's winner is the Unstoppable
roronua Zorro showing Breakneck
development in his conquerors haki not
too long ago kaido had hinted at the
swordsman's latent potential and now
Zorro has delivered perhaps his most
brilliant fight yet against an equally
awe-inspiring opponent King the Wildfire
zoro's takedown of the head All-Star is
one of the grandest spectacles we'll be
left with after the battles on
onigashima are over second only to the
Luffy kaido fight the contest between
the lieutenants has many spine chilling
moments with zoro's sword enma acting up
repeatedly and King showing the magical
Beauty strength and resilience of a now
extinct Warrior tribe pushed to the
brink of death time and time again
zoro's selflessness when it comes to
keeping his promise has long since
established his status as the future
pirate kings first made here too he
takes a miracle drug with unknown and
dangerous after effects to be battle
ready for the clash with the King
despite the risks he fights recklessly
with no regard for his own life turning
out his Harkey Alpha to the max playing
full well that it might just kill him
it's yet another proud moment for our
favorite Moss head and completely
deserving of today's top rank
foreign
that brings us to the end of the top 10
one-piece conquerors haki moments
brought to you by none other than Vinnie
tube if the video got you thinking then
do make sure you leave a comment and of
course don't forget to like subscribe
and ring the notification Bell thanks
for watching till the end and I'll see
you soon with another video